bonjour à tous du coup aujourd'hui c'est
un sujet ultra délicat ultra créative
ans qui va sans doute énervé pas mal de
gens de tous les partis et vous demande
de faire preuve d'un maximum de
bienveillance s'il vous plaît de
bienveillance envers moi en particulier
est depuis en veillant envers tout le
monde en fait dans les commentaires si
vous plaît restez calme si on va avoir
une discussion bienveillante et
constructive
un débat intéressant utile sur un sujet
ô combien difficile alors pour commencer
je vais commencer par m'excuser parce
que le titre de cette vidéo est
mensonger malheureusement je ne suis pas
vegan qui m'arrive souvent
malheureusement de manger des choses
issues de l'élevage animal et je m'en
excuse
et je vous expliquerai pourquoi est ce
que c'est encore le cas malheureusement
en fin de vidéo
nous avons ce que j'aimerais faire un
petit retour en arrière vous parler un
peu de mon parcours alimentaire moi j'ai
juillet tu m'as bien que je leur dise
une fois mes idoles vietnamienne en
france en plus voix et ces deux pays qui
adore manger de la viande
du coup j'ai mangé de la viande compte
une éducation jusqu'à même très
récemment
je suis même mangé beaucoup de gens
parce que ces cultures ça se fait et
c'est même très rare de ne pas manger de
viande dans un repas et voilà je
mangeais beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
viande dans ma vie et le truc c'est que
j'adore la viande je trouve ça vraiment
délicieux voilà j'ai pas choisi de
trouver sa délicieuse je fais pas exprès
de je trouvais ça délicieux mais il se
trouve que un morceau de viande
ça me semble tellement plaisir quel truc
c'est que pendant longtemps du coup
quand je me prenais des remarques un peu
violente venant de personnes un peu
virulente qui défendent le véganisme de
façon
très hardcore ça me donnait absolument
pas envie de manger la viande
au contraire ça me renforcer dans mon
idée que il fallait être un petit peu
trop bizarre pour pouvoir vouloir
arrêter de manger de la viande et du
coup j'ai associé le fait de ne pas
manger la viande avec quelque chose de
finalement assez négatif tout ça pour
dire que globalement les commentaires
très virulent qui défendent le véganisme
et qui s'attaque du coup à la viande de
façon générale on était en tout cas pour
moi extrêmement néfaste puisqu'ils ont
beaucoup retardé ma réflexion autour de
ce que je mange
et en plus de cela comme c'était assez
virulent que ça me mettait un peu sur la
défensive
j'avais tendance à développer des
raisonnements de motiver simplement des
arguments de rationalisation par exemple
on est en avance importante au gré des
traditions ne pas vexer les différentes
cultures à gauche qu'à droite
et ce ne sont pas des mauvais arguments
sont des arguments tout à fait valide
mais bien sûr c'était des arguments dont
la valeur était finalement assez faible
comparé à aux arguments très bons
arguments en faveur du véganisme et
surtout c'était du raisonnement motivé
de ma part c'est à dire que c'est des
arguments que je sortais non pas parce
que je pensais qu'il faisait vraiment
une grande différence dans
l'argumentaire pour ou contre manger de
la viande mais parce que il me
permettait de justifier ma position et
mes habitudes
du coup pendant longtemps même si
j'étais au courant de l'argument de la
souffrance animale et de l'argument
environnemental
j'ai eu tendance à complètement les
négligés parce que j'étais dans ce mode
défensif de raison motivée face à une
virulence qui semblait très critiquable
et du coup j'avais l'impression d'avoir
tout à fait raison propose par
apposition ii par opposition à ceux qui
étaient beaucoup trop virulent dans leur
manière de débattre et dont
l'argumentaire était souvent assez
finalement banques allouent assez peu
bienveillant finalement en plus de cela
la manière dont ils débattent et ne
donnait pas envie de réfléchir davantage
de ce sujet et puis c'est finalement
j'ai continué à manger de la viande
pendant si longtemps c'est avant tout
finalement parce que je n'ai jamais pris
le temps de bien réfléchir à ce sujet
parce qu'à chaque fois que ce sujet
était amené il n'était pas à mener de
façon à m'amener à réfléchir et été
amenée de façon à vouloir me faire
changer d'avis sans prendre le temps de
me faire réfléchir
quand je pense qu'il s'agit d'un sujet
en fait un peu compliqué pas ultra
compliqué c'est pas le plus compliqué
des sujets
centre apparaît sur scène sora mais
c'est un sujet quand même un petit peu
pompier il faut prendre le temps de
réfléchir qui est un peu contre contre
intuitif et surtout sur lequel il est
très facile de tomber dans des
raisonnements motivé que ce soit d'un
côté ou de l'autre
du coup qu'est ce qui a changé qu'est-ce
qui a fait que un jour j'ai commencé à
me dire bah en fait finalement fera
peut-être que je change les habitudes
alimentaires bien ce qui a changé c'est
vraiment un environnement social je vois
je commençais à avoir des amis
végétariens et j'ai notamment rencontré
le mouvement est très efficace qui
mettait beaucoup en avant les problèmes
d'éthique animal surtout qu'il faisait
ça de façon réfléchie de façon
intelligente et de façon motivante et
stimulant intellectuellement que de
réfléchir a finalement quels sont les
fondements de la morale et pourquoi un
finalement est ce que manger de la
viande n'était même pas franchement
franchement quelque chose de désirable
est également rencontrant des gens du
côté de l'écologie qui avaient beaucoup
plus quantifier les dommages de la
viande
évidemment le truc qui m'a pas mal
frappé moi c'est vraiment le point de la
déforestation le pré le fait que
aujourd'hui d'énormes quantités des
espaces ont été transformés en terres
agricoles alors quelle base c'était des
forêts et si vous allez dans une forêt
ben vous voyez que la quantité de
matière de carbone qui ont emmagasiné
par les arbres et juste construisent
tout ça c'est en fait du stockage de co2
sous la forme de de carbone ou en boîte
en fer l'excellente vidéo de veritas un
petit bernard de se rendre compte à quel
point c'est fou que les plantes cro 6
grâce à cette photo synthèse qui
permettent d'absorber du co2 de couper
le co2 en carbone en dioxygène une fois
que nous y peu les forêts sont vraiment
des puits stockage du carbone à très
grande échelle sur de très grands
espaces une fois que me suis vraiment
dit ça notamment suite à un voyage en
birmanie où j'avais du mal à trouver de
la forêt
lorsque je me suis rendu compte de ça je
me suis dit en fait il ya vraiment un
problème avec la déforestation qui est
lié à la manière dont on produit de la
nourriture et qui est lié en particulier
à cet élevage extensif qui fait qu' on
utilise beaucoup plus de terres dont on
aurait vraiment besoin
voilà tout ça pour dire que ce sont
finalement des argumentaires extrêmement
bienveillant actuellement posées alex
moment réfléchit c'est vraiment
finalement des gens qui débattait bien
qu'ils m'ont amené à vraiment me
questionner à me faire changer les
habitudes alimentaires me dire bon bah
finalement c'est vrai qu'il ya quelque
chose à faire vraiment sur la manière
dont on consomme hôtel hôtel nourriture
et du coup j'ai décidé finalement de
manger de moins en moins de viande et
c'était pas facile au début de mois j'ai
moins de viande j'avais l'impression de
passer pour un végétarien ou un des
gannes ce que j'étais devenu mais c'est
difficile de le dire publiquement
je savais vraiment l'impression de me
déclarer comme appartenant à un
mouvement dans lequel je ne me reconnais
pas et donc encore là une fois la
virulence de certains mouvements vegan
m'a ralenti temps
envie de manger moins de viande et
finalement si vraiment j'avais fait ce
pas finalement le truc le plus vraiment
le plus convaincu c'est vraiment d'avoir
des amis bienveillants qui était vegan
et qu'ils échangeaient le véganisme de
manière très bienveillante et qui
charest qui avait vraiment en tête
il est de faire un maximum de bien et y
compris mon bien personnel ils n'ont pas
poussé à être vegan ils sont juste -
accompagner dans ce mouvement pour moi
on parle on régule armand de nourriture
mais sans jamais mais à chaque fois que
j'ai avec plus envie d'en parler il le
sentait du quiz arrêter d'en parler et
c'est vraiment ce cet effort de créer
une curiosité chez moi sur qu'est ce
qu'il faudrait faire de m'accompagner
sans trop me pousse et qui m'a fait
changer mes habitudes alimentaires le
petit à petit en plus j'ai commencé à
voir ça un peu plus comme un défi une
exploration finalement moi j'ai moins de
vent de ces films en tester des voitures
un peu différente et comme j'aime bien
testé chez quelqu'un d'assez furieux
façon générale bah ça me fait marrer
d'essayer de manger des choses
différentes des choses dont je mens je
mange d'habitude c'est celle il ya
encore un autre aspect très important
qui m'a vraiment permis d'être
tranquille dans ce dans ce mécanisme
c'est le fait que en tout cas ici on en
suisse où j'habite il ya eu de plus en
plus de produits d'origine végétale qui
sonde à foz y en a qui ressemble un peu
la viande et qui ont énormément gagné en
qualité et ça c'est vraiment cours des
quelques derniers mois ses recrues quand
j'ai commencé à essayer de manger moins
de viande il n'y avait pas ces produits
et jeu testé beaucoup de burgers
végétarienne de steak végétariens et que
j'ai trouvé vraiment dégoûtant et mais
petit à petit je trouve qu'elle a
quittée s'est vraiment améliorée à tel
point qu'aujourd'hui il a vraiment des
produits que je suis content de manger
et du coup une grande partie de ce
mouvement de ce changement alimentaire
chez moi c'est vraiment aussi l'offre
le fait qu'il y ait ces produits faibles
coûts et de très grande qualité et je
pense que c'est une variable très très
importante pour changer les habitudes
des gens leur volonté propre bien sûr ma
volonté propre à jouer quelque part j'ai
envie de dire ou plutôt l'influencé des
gens autour de moi sur ce que je
préférais mais un autre aspect très
important c'est l'offre les produits qui
étaient proposées et ça c'est le fruit
d' énormes investissements de recharge
pour essayer d en utilisant le circuit
classique de l'économie de proposer
néanmoins des solutions pour réduire la
souffrance animale ou les problèmes
écologiques moi tout ça pour dire que
finalement mes changements de
comportements alimentaires ils sont dus
à pas mal de facteurs en grande partie
je pense que c'est dû à des bâtons des
gens qui autour de moi des maths et
beaucoup mieux que les gens qui
cherchaient à me rendre vegan avant et
dont les discours étaient beaucoup trop
virulent et finalement extrêmement
contre-productif il ya le fait qu'ils
ont essayé à tourner cette question en
une question qui était stimulante
intellectuellement alors ça c'est un
truc marche particulièrement bien sûr
moi en tout cas si un sujet estimant
intellectuellement ça va me donner
beaucoup plus envie de m'y intéresser
sinon je pense à ignorer des sujets qui
sont importants moralement mais sur
lesquels j'ai pas l'impression de
pouvoir beaucoup progressé en
réfléchissant
ouais c'est un petit peu bête mais en
tout cas je pense que parmi les gens qui
regardent cette vidéo dans la communauté
sant warhol je pense qu'il ya pas mal de
gens qui sont un peu comme ça donc
essayer de voir ce qui est stimulant
intellectuellement ce qui pourrait
attirer l'attention des gens et les
faire réfléchir
c'est aussi un aspect important jugement
se débat tant mieux et puis enfin il y à
l'aspect un peu économique de tout ça
qui est extrêmement important donc ils
rentrent pas dans le cadre des bâtons
vieux mais c'est un point je pense aux
importants et garder en tête les grands
changements peuvent venir tout
simplement d'une offre de produits
différents
alors janvier un bémol par rapport à
tout ça j'aimerais pouvoir dire que je
suivais gagnent mais je ne suis pas
parce que je me cormier comme us
la première est la principale raison
pour laquelle m'arrive de manger de la
viande de temps en temps c'est par
rapport à un problème de coût social
notamment ça m'arrive souvent d'être
invités à des conférences avec des
buffets ou des plats servis que je n'ai
pas choisi et du cou ou parfois je ne
sais même pas s'il doit venir de
l'intérieur
pâques est de 208 ch c'est pas ce qui
est à l'intérieur
or j'ai parfois de visu j'essaie de les
choisir s'il n'y a pas de viande mais
parfois juste je n'arrive pas à savoir
et je n'ai pas non plus envie de me
poser des questions métaphysiques parce
que je suis un événement souvent il ya
déjà des personnes très intéressante et
qui parlait et soins je suis souvent
très prisé du coup justement j'ai
parfois c'est un peu difficile pour moi
et du coup bah je prends un truc à
manger et comment ça pas faire attention
énormément si c'est la viande si on sert
un truc comme ça à manger que j'ai fait
un bon bah je mange ce concert puis
aussi le fait que j'ai pas envie de
faire chier moment aussi je vais pas
envie de passer pour le vegan relou qui
va plus énervés les gens autour qu'autre
chose et du coup dans ce genre de
contexte malheureusement j'ai tendance à
manger de la viande
j'essaie de motiver un petit peu plus à
essayer de néanmoins ne pas manger ou de
faire en sorte que
sans passer pour mettre mes chronos mais
voilà peut-être dû faire comprendre aux
gens que ça serait bien s'il y avait
quelque chose de végétariens sans être
trop trop chiant envers eux mais c'est
pas facile
ce qui est pire c'est en famille en
famille dort la viande de la famille du
coup des lectures des plats de viande
qui sont servis et parfois c'est très
mal vu on ne pas manger de pouvoir et je
pense à à manger encore une fois c'est
une question de coût social trop
important ça m'embête de ne pas passer
du bon temps
lorsque je suis en famille la deuxième
raison pour laquelle je ne suis pas
vegan c'est que quand en face et dans
des contextes où le choix est un peu
réduit où c'est un peu plus compliqué où
il ya une question de choses plus
pratiques que d'autres
j'ai tendance à ne pas trop hésité à
manger du fromage ou des pâtisseries
j'ai quand les tendances à conseil que
c'est moins mal que de manger de la
viande du coup j'ai tendance à plus être
plus m'autoriser à manger ça même si je
sais que c'est pas top
l'autre raison aussi pour la connaître
c'est que j'aime ça j'aime j'aime le
fromage j'aime les pâtisseries et comme
le coût est plus faible
bon bah je vous dis que c'est plus
acceptable de manger ce genre de choses
enfin un troisième moment un truc qui
pourrait être choquant pour certains et
je suis désolé si ça vous choque
mais ce sont des trucs comme les fruits
de mer ou les insectes pour lesquels
pour le coup j'ai assez peu de remords à
manger tous à la fois parce que je crois
comprendre que les impacts
environnementaux sont beaucoup moindres
que pour tout le reste est également
parce que il me semble qu'en termes de
souffrance animale ça pose moins de
problème mais bon là sur thalassa ce
débat mais c'est l'impression que j'ai
et sachant que ces produits apportent
des protéines qui sont difficiles à
avoir avec un régime
comment vegan et que aussi je commence à
aimer ce genre de nourriture
baget trans am les autoriser également
et enfin la mer chose qui nous distingue
peut-être de certains vegan c'est que si
jamais il y à de la viande propres
à coût raisonnable et ce même si ces
deux ou trois fois plus cher que la
viande d'élevage
si alice iliad à viande de synthèse de
parfois appelée propres sachant que
cette viande a aucune souffrance animale
e lle est produit avec un coût
environnemental beaucoup moindre que la
viande aux caciques beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup moindres pour coup j'ai très
très peu de remords morales a mangé ce
genre de viande et même au contraire
j'ai tendance à penser que développer
l'industrie de ce genre de viande de
synthèse est extrêmement important parce
que c'est ce qui va permettre
potentiellement à des millions voire des
milliards de gens d'avoir une
consommation alimentaire qui dont le
l'impact environnemental ou sur la
souffrance animale est beaucoup moindre
du coup je pense que s'il y avait de la
viande de synthèse à des prix
relativement abordable jean jetterait un
peu dessus pour essayer de développer
notamment ce marché et diminuer le prix
de cette viande parce qu'après il y aura
des désinvestissements priori le coût ne
cesse de diminuer et si je peux aider je
serais heureux des liens plus en plus
satisfaits mon goût pour la viande
donc voilà j'espère que cette vidéo à
vous a pas trop choquer et j'espère
surtout que vous serez bienveillant dans
les commentaires j'ai plein de défauts
je suis désolé pour tous tous mes
défauts
s'il vous plaît si vous vous souvenez
mais des fois si vous voulez me
critiquer s'il vous plaît soyez
bienveillant dans le critique et essayer
un enterrement d'utiliser le coutil
moines qu'outil ressentirait beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup mieux que si vous
mettiez des commentaires directement
virulent donc s'il vous plaît si vous
mettez les critiques penser aux conti
lemon kuji également penser à vos
premiers conseils que j'ai donné dans la
vidéo précédente